وايماني لم يتغير بان المفاوضات ستنطلق او
سنبدا بتحسسها في غضون نهايه هذا العام
والاسباب وراء ذلك كثيره من ضمنها الهجوم
الاوكراني هذا الذي بدا وايضا الانتخابات
الامريكيه وايضا في عدد اخر من الدول التي
لها علاقه بالحرب كما ان مخصصات اوكرانيا
في الموازنه الامريكيه لها دخل لا سيما مع
بدء موسم الموازنه ومناقشتها في المؤسسات
الامريكيه والتي تبلغ ذروتها في سبتمبر
واكتوبر عندما يتم الكشف عن الارقام
لمناقشتها وفي حاله اوكرانيا خصص الكونغرس
عام 2022 ما لا يقل عن
113.1 مليار دولار اما اداره بايدن
والبنتاجون فقد خصص اقل من عشره هذا العام
ولذلك من الواضح انهما ينظران للكونجرس
لضخ المزيد ويمكن ان يكون 50 مليارا
اضافيا
انا على ثقه بانه في كل الاحوال ستكون
هناك مفاوضات وانا ايضا مستمر بالاقتناع
بان دول شرق اوسطيه على الارجح ستشرف
وتلعب دورا رئيسيا فيها مثل ما لعبت
السعوديه دورا في تبادل السجناء او تركيا
ناهيك انني ارجح ان تحتضنها انقره مثلا
خاصه ان تركيا هي من ترعى مبادره البحر
الاسود للحبوب كل ذلك يعزز قناعتي باننا
سنرى مفاوضات بنهايه العام وما اعلمه وهو
ينطوي على شيء من الرعب هو ان الرئيسيين
بوتيننسكي مقتنعان بان الحرب ستستمر الى
ان يتم حل مسالتين اثنتين
اولهما هو توقف الدول عن دعمهم بان هناك
دولا تدعم اوكرانيا ولكنها في نفس الوقت
تضخ الاموال في الاقتصاد الروسي مقابل
صادرات محدده وثانيا حتى يبلغ عدد القتلى
مستوى يتطلب توقف الحرب
[موسيقى]